the ps4 neo has finally been shown to
the world officially called the
PlayStation 4 Pro Sony showed off the
system at their PlayStation meeting
earlier today the ps4 pro will come with
a one terabyte hard drive double the GPU
power of the original PlayStation 4 and
technology adapted from AMD Polaris
graphical architecture Sony says this
will allow the ps4 pro to reach
resolutions not thought possible on
consoles in 2016 a number of games
running on the ps4 pro and 4k were shown
such as already released games like Lord
of the Rings shadows of Mordor and Deus
Ex mankind divided as well as not yet
released games like insomniac spider-man
game horizon zero dawn Call of Duty
infinite warfare and Mass Effect
Andromeda Sony also showed off the
improved color of games with HDR support
which will be included in all models of
the ps4 via a system update next week
sony says that patches for over a half
dozen sony titles are in the works to
take advantage of ps4 Pro and many
third-party developers are also working
on releasing patches to take advantage
of the new hardware on the video end a
new Netflix app will be available and
upcoming exclusives such as Marvel's
Luke Cage and narcos season 2 will
support 4k streaming a new youtube app
will also be available for 4k streaming
4k blu-ray for the ps4 pro was not
mentioned during the meeting and it has
been confirmed it will not be supported
the playstation 4 pro will launch on
November 10th for 399 you SDS or 345
pounds in the UK for all the latest news
on the playstation 4 pro stay tuned game
spot